alors c'est une fraise qui a été
réalisée par des lycées et des collèges
de la région du Poitou donc à côté de
Poitiers c'est pas c'est pas une fresque
qui vient directement de mon territoire
mais j'ai trouvé le projet très
intéressant et donc c'est une fraise qui
qui est une fresque en réalité augmentée
et qui parle de l'égalité fille garçon
et qui délivre un certain nombre de
messages très intéressants sur l'égalité
fille garçon alors je la trouve
extraordinaire parce qu'elle a été faite
par des jeunes qui apportent leur
témoignage et en plus elle est en
réalité augmentée c'est à dire que avec
un téléphone vous la scanner et vous
allez avoir des témoignages qui
apparaissent sur les photos donc je
trouve ça plutôt sympa parce que c'est
un j'allais dire un truc mais c'est une
fresque qui est pleine de témoignages
pleine de d'empathie entre des enfants
qui parlent de l'égalité femme et en
même temps c'est un objet technologique
que je trouve intéressant pour permettre
de de délivrer un certain nombre de
messages sur cette question égalité
fille garçon et puis on a voulu la voir
cette semaine pour la
l'anniversaire de la loi sur le
harcèlement scolaire qui a un an
maintenant et cette loi elle ne pourquoi
pas parler de qualité fille garçon
autour de cette loi parce que c'est
aussi un des sujets sur les questions de
harcèlement c'est parfois des sujets de
gens parfois des sujets de différence et
cette presse qui explique plein de
choses intéressantes sur cette question
donc voilà pourquoi on a voulu l'avoir
ici et puis et ben on est en plein coeur
de l'Assemblée nationale en plein cœur
de la représentation nationale tout à
l'heure comme tous les chaque début de
séance la présidente de l'Assemblée est
passée devant et je trouvais le symbole
intéressant de la voir ici tout près de
la statue de l'Olympe de bouse pour
parler d'égalité famome et d'égalité
fille garçon alors aujourd'hui par la
loi que que l'on a fait voter il y a un
an maintenant on a normalement une
obligation dans chacun des
établissements scolaires de toute la
France quel que soit le type
d'établissement d'avoir des plans de
prévention des plans de lutte contre le
harcèlement scolaire alors ça se met en
place dans l'éducation nationale avec le
programme PHARE et pour le reste des
établissements ils ont le choix de
mettre en place le dispositif qui
souhaite mais en tout cas maintenant il
est obligatoire d'avoir dans chaque
collège dans chaque lycée dans chaque
école dans chacune université même un
plan de prévention contre le harcèlement
scolaire et universitaire ça c'est une
des avancées de ce texte l'autre avancée
c'est l'accompagnement des victimes et
aussi des auteurs on parle souvent des
victimes mais il faut aussi accompagner
les auteurs et puis le troisième volet
du texte c'est le volet protection avec
la définition d'un délit pénal de
harcèlement scolaire les étapes c'est
que aujourd'hui on a à mon sens on a
aujourd'hui tous les outils législatifs
pour mener le combat maintenant il faut
que la société prenne conscience du
sujet trop encore trop souvent le
harcèlement scolaire est considéré comme
des chamailleries entre enfants contre
des choses qui ne sont comme quelque
chose qui n'est pas très grave alors que
c'est très grave et chaque situation de
harcèlement scolaire peut conduire à des
drames les drames parfois on les
connaissent et le suicide de certains
enfants mais ça peut aussi être la
déscolarisation les difficultés
scolaires la perte de confiance de de
l'élève et quand un élève perd confiance
en ses camarades hyper confiance en
l'institution scolaire quelque part
hyper confiance aussi en la société et
on peut pas tolérer ça donc les
prochaines étapes c'est cette prise de
conscience nécessaire qui doit qui doit
continuer et puis les moyens les moyens
supplémentaires qui doivent être mis
dans chaque établissement pour parler du
sujet pour mener ces politiques de
prévention ces politiques de lutte et
ces politiques d'accompagnement et puis
il y a un grand sujet qui doit que l'on
doit continuer à travailler et
aujourd'hui sans il y a un texte sur le
sur ces questions là aussi c'est
l'accompagnement des mineurs sur le
sujet des écrans leur exposition aux
écrans l'exposition dans les réseaux
sociaux les bonnes pratiques des réseaux
sociaux et puis j'insiste aussi
là-dessus le rôle des parents les
parents qui doivent accompagner leurs
enfants accompagner leurs enfants dans
la protection d'en faire faire attention
à ce qu'ils regardent mais aussi
accompagner les enfants dans ce qu'ils
disent et les enfants parfois ils sont
victimes de harcèlement scolaire mais
parfois ils sont aussi harceleurs et les
parents ont une responsabilité de faire
très attention à ce que disent les
enfants et donc c'est tout ça qu'il faut
continuer à faire et c'est un combat qui
est important parce qu'une société où on
commence sa vie sociale dans un milieu
hostile via le harcèlement c'est une
société qui n'est pas une société où on
va avancer sereinement et je pense que
ça peut conduire à des dégâts sur le
long terme donc il faut continuer cette
lutte contre le harcèlement scolaire
d'arrache-pied et d'une manière plus
générale il faut qu'on ait une école où
chaque élève chaque professeur chaque
membre de la de la communauté éducative
se sente bien se sentent dans un milieu
apaisé dans un milieu où règne
l'empathie la sympathie la bonne
camaraderie entre tous les acteurs et
j'espère que on va continuer enfin
j'espère je suis sûr qu'on va continuer
ce combat et j'espère que ce texte qui a
maintenant un an il contribuera